the time being
9 30
i am going to call this executive
session
of public works and highways
to order
and
my vice chair just called he's stuck in
traffic for a minute so i'm going to
recess until
9 40 when we will resume
okay
um
so
oh
they talked about
thanks
time being
10 40
i call the
executive session of house public works
to order
i would remind everybody
on the committee and in the audience
that this is a public meeting not a
public hearing the purpose of the
executive session is for the members of
the committee
to decide what we will recommend
to the full house for a vote on
the bills before us it is my intention
to finish all of the bills that are
currently within the
possession of the committee today
um so that we don't have to come back
between now and the the ninth of
march which would be the deadline on all
of these bills
so
the first one
two weeks ago we had the beginning of
the
executive session
on house bill 2022
i would call the executive session on
house bill 2022
back into session
there you go
thank you mr chair uh mr chair i would
like to make a motion of
ought to pass on amendment number
to
h
this uh this event go ahead
is there a second
second
represent representative mills moves
amendment
[Music]
0745 h
seconded by representative mcconkey uh
representative mills is recognized to
speak
uh yes thank you mr chairman
this amendment covers
uh all of the
well i shouldn't say all of them one two
three four
of the um
straw vote
that we had
two weeks ago
the one of them that we dropped i we
elected to drop off
was the
location of the toll plaza
when we did some investigation the
location of the toll plazas is normally
what is your point of order point of
order is
i was informed that we were working on
amendment ending in seven
but he is explaining what what happened
at the last executive session and what
we have changed since that last
executive session which you were not at
representative boyd i appreciate that
i appreciate that
the question we are still gonna i'm
gonna let him speak okay fair enough mr
chairman thank you
so in any case uh the uh
the uh actual final location of the
tolls
in merrimack is normally a budget item
and it has traditionally never been put
thank you mr chair um i am speaking in
in support of the um amendment that's
before us today zero seven four five h
i think it has been
traditional in this committee to
really look at the history of what
happened in merrimack and i'm not from
merrimack so i don't presume to know
every single bit of history of this but
our understanding has always been that
the ramp tolls were placed
in a
negotiation
with the state of new hampshire whereby
the state of new hampshire got involved
with continental boulevard its
maintenance etc
and so
to me
although some folks feel that merrimack
is targeted
i think to many people on this committee
we see it more as a um as fair
to
if the if the toll booths are in fact
returned
or gotten rid of that they
go ahead and and take over the um
the maintenance again of continental
boulevard so just by way of uh the cost
analysis um just so we get this into the
record we did ask
d.o.t to go ahead and
estimate for us the loss of total
revenue to the turnpike
and cumulatively
uh annually and this relates to the time
of removal so i will say that with the
egg when they removed exit 10 we were in
covid so the
the revenues may have been slightly
less than usual
it was 1.7 million in net revenue loss
annually at the time of removal
the cost to remove the three toll plazas
was 1.9 million
the cost to remove the remnants of the
ramp toll with tunnels
etc is going to be 4 million dollars so
you can add those numbers up
the annual
maintenance cost of continental
boulevard is eighty thousand dollars and
it was last repaved in 2017
for seven hundred thousand dollars
so i thought
it would be good to at least get on the
record the costs uh that we're engaged
in here when we're in this discussion
and also
my understanding is that the bond that
relates to
continental boulevard is not yet repaid
so
um
i would say that's the end of my
statement for now but uh
i just wanted to share the the costs and
where some of the at least i think a lot
of the members of this committee are
thank you representative eagle
um
further discussion
representative boyd
mr chairman thank you and uh through you
to my
esteemed colleagues of the general
general court i am in opposition
to the amendment
the state
uh specifically the department of
transportation has been trying
to
the lack of a better word unload
continental boulevard onto merrimack
along with the associated cost
a road which from the town standpoint
does not have any direct flow
in main flow as it relates to the town
the specific role of continental
boulevard in question is to serve as an
artery of feeder road from route 101
coming up to industrial drive to ask to
access the turnpike
based on
preliminary cost to assume
responsibility of this road would be 200
200 000 annually to the town with the
potential long-term costs of over the
next 20 years of 2.5 2.5 million dollars
for this specific road which would
include the hiring of an additional
operator and potentially another piece
of equipment
town is is not prepared
nor
did we want to accept responsibility
for this particular road because of the
increased cost of this particular road
it is difficult for me
as as a member of the community of
merrimack
to
ask
the state for us to assume to assume not
just the short-term but the long-term
burden of maintaining a road
that honestly was the state's
responsibility to provide
a specific arterial flow through that
through that section of merrimack and
the
i would humbly ask all of you to oppose
the amendment because this is this is a
specific form of downshifting
of the state responsibility onto the
town of merrimack and by no means
as it relates to the removal of the
tolls
that that was included when the tolls
were being removed that that was
included in the conversation that we
would assume responsibility of
continental boulevard that's that's
you know if any
if you're
thinking that there never was a part of
the conversation or the equation so i
would sincerely ask my colleagues to
oppose the amendment thank
you representative jack
thank you mr chairman uh i would point
out to everyone that the that the
turnpike system is a zero-sum game
because every dollar of work that funds
the turnpike system it comes from toll
collection
if you reduce toll collection you reduce
the amount of work
that can be done and because the bond
covenants require that preservation be
done before new construction
any dollar that is spent on continental
boulevard will
act to delay new construction on the
turnpike such as the widening project
that runs through merrimack
and that's not an outcome that we want
further discussion
on the amendment
we have concentrated on one paragraph is
there any discussion on the other
elements within the amendment that we
did discuss at our last
c none are we ready for the vote
all those in favor of amendment zero
seven four five eight signify by saying
aye aye
opposed
nay
um
the eyes have it and amendment 0745h
is
adopted
what is the pleasure of the committee
now that we have adopted amendment
0745h
representative mcconkey uh thanks
thank you mr chairman i would like to
move
house bill 2022 as amended
ought to pass
representative mcconkey moves out to
pass as amended on house bill 2022
seconded by representative eaton
is there any discussion
on
the motion of ought to pass as amended
representative boyd
thank you mr chairman and again i am
opposed to this amendment
as it dramatically impacts
the
legacy
that
my predecessor former speaker dick hinch
did in warning
to eliminate the tolls at exits 10 11
and 12.
by proposing to move this overhead plaza
south of those egg exits it diminishes
that that is not part of this amendment
we adopted amendment 745.
i apologize mr chairman i thought we
were
any further discussion seeing none the
clerk will call the roll
okay
thank you mr chair
representative mcconkey
i
the clerk votes yes
representative close
yes
representative folson yes
representative post
yes
representative nelson
representative boards
no
representative alexander yes
representative mcdonald
yes
representative thompson
yes representative boyd
boyd votes nay
representative cloudier yes
representative edgar aye
representative ebel yes
representative jack yes representative
abbott yes
representative faulkner yes
representative newman yes
representative eaton
representative peterson yes
representative query
yes
mr chair of the total vote is
i'm sorry
yes
write a note at the bottom yeah
mr chair the vote is 21 to 2 off to
passes amended the vote being 21-2
ought to pass as amended is adopted it
will be on the regular calendar will
there be a minority report
i would like to write a minority point
okay um if you could have it to me by
noontime tomorrow i would appreciate it
so i can get it in to the clerk and
moving on to other business excuse me
question mr chairman
certainly yes and that will be on the
regular calendar i assume uh i just said
um
thank you mr chairman
my understanding is that house bill 1432
is still
in possession of the committee and i
would like to move reconsideration
it is the act prohibiting the use of
state funds for passenger rail projects
representative mcconkey
moves that we reconsider our actions
uh previous actions on house bill 1432
who is it
representative boyd seconds
is there any discussion on the motion to
see none
the clerk will call the role on the
motion to reconsider our actions on
thank you mr chair
representative mcconkey aye
representative mills clerk says yes
representative close aye
representative folson aye
representative post
aye
representative nelson
representative borders yes
representative alexander
representative mcdonald yes
no
representative clutier no
representative edgar
nay
representative ebel no
people are going to have to turn their
mics off
now i'm good uh no
representative abbott
no
representative faulkner no
representative newman no
representative eaton no
representative query
no
representative bunker
representative graham
yes
mr chair the vote is 11 12
nay
the motion to reconsider
our actions on house bill
1432 fails
um the the
recommendation goes to the house
as
previously
voted on which is
a thai vote so the committee has no
recommendation
for the edification of the members of
the committee the first vote on the
i'd like to open the executive session
on house bill
zero two five five
uh excuse me
house bill 13 10 32
[Music]
which is a bill
uh with that deals with the laconia
state property we have heard the
testimony on that uh what is the
mr j i'd like to make a motion of itl on
that
representative
on
house bill 1032 second name mr chairman
uh seconded by representative boyd
just to remind everybody
um
when we heard this bill which would uh
i don't want anybody to hear me
[Laughter]
um i would just remind everybody that
when we heard the public testimony on
this
and the bill was overturned what was in
house bill 2 on the procedure for sale
of the lakes region
facility
we learned that the governing council
had already sent out an rfp for the sale
and that the mayor of laconia came in
and testified that he was satisfied with
the procedure that was being followed
for the sale of the property
with that
there any further discussion i just
wanted to make sure everybody understood
why the itl motion was probably made
any further discussion if not the clerk
will call the roll
thank you mr chair
representative mcconkey
clerk votes yes
representative close
i
representative folsom aye
representative post
aye
representative nelson
representative bortis
aye
representative alexander yes
representative mcdonald yes
representative thompson yes
representative boyd
representative clutier yeah yes
representative edgar aye representative
ebel yes
representative jack yes
representative abbott yes
representative faulkner yes
representative newman yes
representative eaton aye
representative query yes representative
bunker
yes chairman graham yes
mr chair of the vote is 23-0
the vote being 23-0 on the motion of an
expedience to legislate
um is there any objection to the consent
calendar
the next bill we have up
is house bill 1548 also relating to the
sale of the lakes region facility
we'll take one minute as an amendment is
yes
you want to move the amendment sure okay
okay i think everybody hopefully has a
copy by now
um representative mcconkey
thank you mr chairman i would like to
move
amendment
0756h
[Music]
representative mcconkey has moved
amendment
0756h to house bill
1548 is our second
is seconded by representative clutier
the amendment is now open for discussion
do i see any discussion representative
borders yeah quick question in regards
to this amendment
um it's saying that
uh a portion of
the proceeds of the sale shall be used
to relocate this facility to a new
location
do we have a percentage or are we using
the way i had them drafted where it says
a portion
it is to make sure that
if land is required to be purchased if a
building has to be renovated or if there
is a construction that is needed on the
new emergency center that is currently
located on that facility that is paid
for with those funds so that two years
from now we don't have an agency sitting
before this very committee asking to
borrow 20 or million or whatever the
number might end up being that we would
have to borrow
so if the cash is there from a sale
uh and we're forcing people to move i
think we should use it to do that that's
why
um we had that discussion
among several of the members to do that
um and
i took it upon myself to bring the
amendment in but now it's in the
possession of the committee
so it's up to the committee on whether
or not to accept this or do something
else with the bill
any further discussion
representative edgar
uh thank you mr chairman
uh
i'm wondering is the intent the way it's
written to mean that they would this
building this new facility would also
support both
the 911 center and the lakes region
that is the way it is written and it
would be up to
the lawyers to sort out whether
we could even do it for for somebody
else but it was the intention to move
everybody
ain't no further discussion
um
um i will call for a vote on amendment
0756h
all those in favor of approving the
amendment signify by saying aye
hi opposed nay the ice have it and the
amendment is adopted i will now accept
representative mcconkey um
thank you mr chairman i would like to
move out to pass
on uh house bill 1548. what the passage
is yes
okay on the wrong bill i'm no no you're
on the right bill
um
representative mcconkey moves ought to
pass
as amended on house bill 1548
is there a section i will second that
motion representative clutier seconds
the the motion
thank you mr chair representative
mcconkey
hi
the clerk votes yes
representative close
aye
representative folson hi
representative post
aye
representative nelson
representative bortis
aye
representative alexander
representative mcdonald yes
representative thompson yes
representative claudia yes
representative edgar aye representative
ebel
yes
representative jack yes
representative abbott yes
representative faulkner yes
representative newman
yes
representative eaton bye
representative peterson yes
representative querrey
yes representative bunker yes
chairman graham
yes
mr chair of the vote is 23-0
ought to pass as amended the vote on not
to pass is amended on house bill 1548
being 23 to zero
the motion is adopted
is there any objection from members of
the committee to consent calendar see
none will go on their consent calendar
that
ladies and gentlemen
is all of the bills that we have in the
possession of
the committee at this time
we did not receive any bills
um
from another committee of second
committee on any of the bills that from
our last session of the house
so we will not be meeting again as a
there may be two or more bills that come
from the senate
i will try to schedule the public
hearings on those all on one day
trying to minimize the number of times
people have to drive down here
but i do thank everybody for their
patience for those of you who were
subbing for sick or or other absent
members i do appreciate it it is useful
to
have
other people know what the committee
does
but again i want to thank everybody on
the committee for all of their hard work
and i want to thank the department of
transportation
for their input on the entire 10-year
plan
it was invaluable to have your input
even though
you may not like everything we did but
um
it um is still useful
that being said are there any
comments or
announcements from any members of the
committee mr chairman
and i just want to follow i know i asked
you this question earlier but do you
anticipate
any of these bills that we act on today
being on the next when we meet again as
a full house on march 10th or you you
have to
i can virtually guarantee that the two
that are going on consent calendar will
be on that calendar um the the goal of
the clerk and the speaker is to put
everything that comes in on consent
put it on the calendar
move the bills forward there are still
several hundred bills
that the house has to deal with over the
next month
um
so it depends on how many bills
come come in whether or not the 10-year
plan is on the next one
i would be willing
to give it
a passing grade on that it will be
just so that it moves forward
but again it depends on
how much
how many other bills come in
and his goal is to try to minimize two
day meetings as you notice in his his
message out to everybody
that
not only are we meeting on the the
10th and 17th and 31st but he also
talked about the 16th
and 30th if needed
hopefully we will
have as many as possible on the 10th
knowing that even if we don't get
through them all
we have the next couple of weeks because
um they are not going too far
any other questions of me
again thank everybody for coming um did
not take quite as long as i thought but
we are finished and i will adjourn
this executive session
and commentary
public works at highway
adjourned
you